we're gonna watch among us in a nutshell
from circle tunes
hd today but first we gotta thank
today's video sponsor
rage shadow legends youtubers being
sponsored by rage shadow legends this is
unprecedented the dark epic fantasy raid
is always
upping the ante with its stories and its
champions with its classic
dungeon crawling rpg once you download
raid for your mobile phone or pc you'll
be hurled into an epic struggle between
more than 12
warring factions factions range from
your classic knights orcs dwarves and
elves to more out there creatures such
as skinwalkers lizard people and a whole
bunch
more blizzard people are real they're
shapeshifters that are descendants of
reptilian beans of the alpha draconis
star system
is this is that a raid lore thing no
it's
it's a real belief oh how do we
transition since halloween's coming up
i've been checking out the undead horde
look at how badass these guys are those
lost souls of the realm are gnarly as
heck and
great in battle it's the result of human
reptilian breeding programs
that have been taking place on earth for
at least 200 000 years
can you stop talking about this please
the user experience is super smooth and
tied together with beautiful graphics
and artist renderings that make
even the load screens beautiful to look
at you can play in complete isolation or
join clans from across the world to
increase your numbers and if you get
good enough you can even start your very
own clan
you need to realize the human race is
slowly being infiltrated by a secret
race of lizard people
this month raid is upping the
competitive nature of their player
versus player battles with huge champion
updates and they've also got a forge
coming up for those of you looking to
deal in top quality
artifacts so don't miss out hit up our
link in the description box or
pin comment and when you download raid
you'll receive 100 000
silver 50 gems one energy refill and a
free champion
straight to your inbox rewards are good
for 30 days once you sign up so hit that
link and join the raid
[Music]
we changed our clothes totally did not
shoot that intro in advance
okay boys let's split up search for
clues do our tasks and find these two
rat bastards trying to kill us
and can we stop throwing out random
people from the ship for
no reason because we think it's funny
can we actually think about who we're
trying to kill
yeah it's so true
what's happening what's wrong i'm
sketched out
that red guy over there hasn't done a
single task you know what
i think he's the murderer i think he's
trying to kill us oh my god
are you this stupid the game has been
going on for like two seconds
i'm skipping this yeah this is stupid as
hell there's no way he's the killer
we're gonna skip this boat too
god damn i'm sorry some people have no
idea how to play this game they're
voting for me
for no reason it happens to me all the
time for me back there thank you
you back there but don't worry i've
already decided
what's that though could have done this
i've got a strong feeling it was you
purple
i saw you walking down the hallway right
next to the body five seconds ago
what what's happening this is my first
game i don't really know what's going on
that's exactly what the murderer said
let's get him boys
yeah it's definitely him this is
brilliant
[Music]
that was brilliant that is exactly the
game
uh that was genius this game
loved it friendships i love that oh
that's hysterical
subscribe to circle tunes hd as soon as
you can
i was brilliant he captured the voice of
every single time i have
ever played this game that's been many
hours of playing this game
and it is the exact voice of how
everyone operates and then i've seen
like my girlfriend show me a bunch of
videos on tick tock as well
and uh you know like there's youtube
videos of it this perfectly
encapsulates the game i know john hasn't
played it yet so i don't i don't know if
you were just confused as to what was
going on
i mean i get the gist of what the game
is about
and it seems very very fun and like it
has the potential to
devolve into chaos and divide a room up
you have to basically just do a bunch of
tasks
but one of you is an imposter on the
spaceship and you're you have to kill
off people
and not get caught essentially is what
the whole thing is but you can't talk to
each other while you're playing the game
until a voting session comes around if
there's like an emergency meeting
happening it's kind of like one of those
like who's the murderer yeah it's like
transpire transposed into a game yeah
it's like mafia
or what's that the murder one where
people are you have to figure out who
the killer is
on your crew and the first time i played
this game i thought it was just gonna be
really dull i thought it was gonna be
very boring i didn't know anything about
it i didn't realize that you had to do
tasks people were like do your tasks
your time like what the hell how do you
even find these tasks to do and what he
points out here
about like trying to swipe the card and
do the tasks sometimes it should be like
no problem at times just to do some of
these most
menial tasks but then it could be a real
like challenge just to figure out like
how did you get this done and then
because you're like spending so long
lingering on these spots people will
start to mistake you for the imposter
and every single time that i'm accused
of being the imposter
i can't there's no way i can find my way
i've never been able
to properly i just i give up right there
and then even if i know i'm not the
imposter
i just give up right then and there i'm
like all right you guys are you guys are
gonna vote for me no matter what i say
i always sound like i'm sarcastic i'm
just gonna let you guys vote me off and
and be wrong even though i know who the
imposter is no one's gonna believe me on
this
okay wait wait wait do you have to argue
like on your own behalf or there are
commands
in the game that you have to enter no
when it comes time to vote for people
that's when you can start talking with
everyone you're playing with and so you
can start being like i saw him over here
i saw him kill her i totally killed my
girlfriend last time
uh wishful wish fulfillment
we had amazing amazing
cuddle session afterwards um no i don't
want to play this game with you
and then when i'm an imposter uh i'm the
worst at
hiding it i i already get accused all
the time of being the imposter
when when i'm not the ambassador when i
am i
i just i i suck at uh keeping it
concealed but yeah people are often
too quick to kill as he points out in
this video too i don't feel like people
put enough thought
into thinking about who you're trying to
kill oh yeah it can be very upsetting
well you know if you've got like tasks
and if there's any element of time
just like people get paranoid and people
also want to win and want to be right
and
people take those swings but this is uh
this was a brilliant video i thought he
really captured the panicking voice and
i love the additional violence that you
threw on here as well this was this is
hilarious i want to check out more
circle tunes hd this was great and i
like really love that joke too of oh i
feel like we're bonding i feel like
we're bonding with each other you're the
imposter
this is so accurate man oh my gosh
i want to play now surprisingly
brilliant among us too uh i think it's
actually trending on twitter right now
is
cancelled because the developers the
tweets they made back in the day
yeah man really inappropriate stuff and
not for video games
so among us two is canceled because
apparently
they want to focus on updating among us
part one
adding new elements to it but also
updating i think like i don't know the
technical words to it all but you know
all the software integration because
they were not expecting
such such massive growth such
massive usage such massive popularity
so now they're just working their asses
off to make sure
that among us one can still be playable
and not be glitching out all the time
while also advancing it and i think
that's very exciting you know because
they were supposed to have among those
two come out i think sometime in august
of next year could be wrong about that
but i'm really
really happy for them it's really cool
to know that such a a simple
little game like among us it's a really
simple game with not the craziest of
graphics but during this time of covid
during this time of quarantine
i really feel like a game like among us
has really helped with feeling like
you're truly bonding with friends in the
perfect social distancing manner kudos
to the among us people great game
to play on your phone or on computer
seriously all right guys well you're a
big fan of among us
are you which are you good at uh being
the imposter are you good at keeping
that identity concealed let us know
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
and thank you to rage shadow legends for
sponsoring today's video
that link and last but not least patron
of the day shout out
jay and valente if there's one person i
know
who would be the most successful
imposter in a video game like this
it is undoubtedly j.n valente no joke
that's not a joke at all this guy's
great at being
a wonderful mysterious human being
who you never know when he's gonna just
pop back into your life
at any given moment so jn you are the
number one person i would
absolutely love to play with on among us
i
imagine even when we're trying to vote
on who the imposter is you would just
spew out a whole bunch of nonsense where
we'd all be like this guy's just so
crazy there's no way he could be the
imposter no he's
he this has to be the truth of whatever
stream of consciousness monologuing he's
doing well we're just trying to decide
who to vote on so
j ed i appreciate you still being a part
of our patreon page no idea where you've
been
but let's hope you're not killing people
on the spaceship buddy